everything's a lot of actors kind of
keep souvenirs and things did you get
any kind of trinkets from the set yes
yeah well they wouldn't give me my sword
which was very annoyed about I know I
know I don't know I know I should have
but I did keep a statue of myself it's
it's me it's all of them actually
what the hell are you going to do with a
statue of yourself well that's what I
asked myself when it arrived now like
what do I do with death in the front
lawn yeah what exactly am I gonna make
it like a water feature out of it yeah
or a shrine of some sort or like a
scarecrow for the vegetable patch
there's lots of things we were talking
about the office I need you should bury
it and then people will find it yes if
someone will buy it by your house and
they'll be doing the garden and they'll
find a statue of Jon Snow oh my God he's
frozen and then they'll be really would
like and he used to live here
why did you because talking about how
many how many of the hammers have you
got now oh I've got like three or four
of them what I didn't ask I was like all
right come with me
doesn't even got the new one I got the
new on the Stormbreaker yeah and I keep
trying to kind of put them up on the
mantelpiece and around the house my wife
kids have like the toy one and then the
other day I got the toy was like oh no
that's the real one ones probably you're
just sitting on the ground with the
guinea pigs and the rabbits kind of
running over could you do Nick things
Julia you know I love a wig
I love a wig so whenever I can although
you can't really you can't really just
take a wig you have to ask because
they're really expensive but if I can if
I can leave a movie with the wig I will
and I've got them all on a box and then
it's a box of hair
because paul rudd you did quite well in
the nicking stakes I have an ant-man
suit like take the whole suit is that
just kind of like oh I think my car's
hereby I asked a lot and about 20 I
finally on the 20th time can I please
can I please and they acquiesced in
marbles very nice and I and they send it
to me and I have it set at the top of
the stairs so that if anybody goes up
the stairs and turns it's right there
and it and with hopes that it will
terrify them and Surprise them
I should probably move it that'll be
nice based viewers your statue on the
landing do you have a landing just move
it around the house yes I have a landing
I could behind a breakfast bar
[Music]